انتصار أجنبي هنا معركة مدفعية لا تزال
تهز مدينة كوبيانسك المحررة ، يبدو
شعار الاحتلال هذا نحن شعب واحد
مع روسيا كوميدي الآن
وقد طارد الأوكرانيون الروس
عبر الجسر وفي الجنوب
سقطت القذيفة على بعد مائة
متر منا
آخر يتبعه بسرعة  من غير المحتمل
أن تتمكن موسكو من استعادة الأماكن التي فقدتها في
الأسابيع الماضية ،
فالأمر يتعلق بالثأر وعلى الرغم من أن
هذا السجين قد ادعى أنه محلي
لكنهم يعتقدون أنه جندي روسي
هرب أو ترك وراءه ما يجب
تركه وراءه هو أقبح بكثير
هذه الغرف الصغيرة كانت احتجازهم
المركز الذي كان يحتجز فيه ما يصل إلى 400
سجين في وقت واحد ، قيل لنا أن ثمانية
أو تسعة سجناء في كل زنزانة ، توجد
الآن أشراك مفخخة في مكانهم.
تم العثور على أفخاخ مفخخة
خلفتها قوات الاحتلال على ما يبدو أن
قنبلة واحدة تركت تحت صينية
نصف مأكولة  الطعام
ويظهر لك فقط المخاطر التي
سيجدها الأشخاص العاديون في العودة
إلى مكان مثل هذا بالتأكيد يستخدم كمركز احتجاز رئيسي من
قبل الروس ، لكن
الضرر غير عادي في جميع أنحاء هذه المدينة ،
ولكن هناك أيضًا
خطران من الذخائر غير المنفجرة وربما
فخاخ مفخخة يكتشفونها
ندبتين أخريين من التعذيب
قدمه لنا هؤلاء السجناء السابقون من قبل
جهاز الأمن الأوكراني الذي يقول
إنه سُجن منذ حوالي شهر ، هل
كان ذات مرة طباخًا في الجيش
الأجنبي وكان الهاتف نموذجًا قديمًا للتصفية
اعتاد على إرسال صدمات كهربائية إليه ، وكان
يعتقد أن محققه كان من ذوي الخبرة
من قبل خدمات الأمن الروسية
، وسألوه من كان على اتصال به
من الجيش ، وأحرق الروس
سجلات استجوابهم على عجل ،
نعم في
أماكن أخرى ، مؤشرات على العقلية التي غذت
الغزو الروسي الذي وجدوه الوقت
ليرسم هذه اللوحة الجدارية ، يرى جندي روسي
حرف Z على ذراعه بجوار أحد المتقاعدين
وعلم الإمبراطورية السوفيتية السابقة
لامع في
توقفت النيران للحظة هنا في إراقة الدماء
والدمار وفكر في مدى غرابة هذا الأمر حقًا
أنهم كانوا هنا فقط منذ بضعة أشهر ، ولكنهم قاموا
بسرعة بشم هذا المبنى
بآلاتهم المؤلمة
للغاية هنا بوضوح بعد استخدام القليل من
السكان المحليين يتجمعون في قشرته الفارغة  الفوز
لا يشفي الجراح فقط يمنحهم
الوقت الكافي ليشعروا بها نيك بايتون
والش سي إن إن كوبيانسك أوكرانيا